all right I'm very pleased to have more
Caleta which here today in in easy is
one of the authors of this paper it's
called algorithmic extremism examining
YouTube's rabbit hole of radicalization
so I've done a video about a topic like
this before actually several and this is
basically one in a line of research that
examines the recommendation algorithm of
YouTube specifically but also kind of
the general social media platforms so
mark thanks for being here
could you maybe for people who do not
know anything about this could you kind
of explain where your work fits into
what's been done before or kind of also
what comes out of the of the mainstream
media about this topic because there's
been quite a bit of of talk yeah so I'm
not a researcher by trade AMA Pro
grandma and the reason why I got into
this was because I could see clear bias
and the way the YouTube recommendation
systems being reported on and also in
the research a there's some narratives I
think it might be because there's a lot
of people worried about rhyming populism
and this is a way to explain that
they're looking for ways YouTube are
radicalizing people and finding evidence
for that or but that could be anecdotes
or in some of the studies at sexual
quantitative data but they're only
looking to confirm it so there's really
obvious things I think you covered in
your video some of them will just look
for movement towards all right channels
through like centrist or out like they
call it instead of looking for both way
it's just really obvious things like
that
calling it calling an infection that
cliche clearly shows that and really
looked at it like a curious person would
so I thought I could easily as a
software engineer just collect all the
data and without any complicated
statistics
just looking at the overall flow of
recommendations between videos what
their political influences yeah this
this was a thing that that bugged me of
the paper that I made a video about is
that they claim there's this
radicalization pipeline right and with
pipeline everyone sort of understands a
different thing but I think the general
consensus is that the recommendation
algorithm itself will steer you towards
like more extreme content and in this
case towards like the alt-right
extremist content and the paper actually
analyzed and said okay we found evidence
that there is movement in this direction
but they never shown that this is
significantly more movement than like in
in the other direction so in order to
justify a pipeline one would need to
show that the movement this way is not
larger than this way in some notion and
so I've I've I've found I've actually
spoken to the author of that paper and
he agrees with that but obviously
doesn't doesn't have like energy to go
into every you know go refute everything
that comes at them they've also been a
bunch of like they've also been exposed
to a lot of criticism let's say as have
you and I think even more when when your
paper came out I think for days there
was just a giant storm of people
attacking your paper basically I just
just listing every single thing that's
wrong with it and why this isn't valid
and things like this so let's actually
jump into what you did specifically so
if if I'm if I'm can summarize and you
can then maybe correct so that we can
establish what happened
you basically collected recommendations
so you scrape these video
on YouTube and you collected these
recommendations and we can we can see
this so in your paper you then can make
such diagrams such as this one or these
where in the middle the white bar is a
channel or a group that you're
interested in and then to the left you
can see where all the impressions of
that channel or group come from
so what's where where basically the
views come from through the
recommendation system and on the right
you can see of all the views that
channel has relief where do they go to
so what what what is recommended next
right so it basically shows both
directions for for every group and then
you've also labeled these by multiple
methods so that you can kind of
establish these groups and what is
pretty cool you've built this website
where you can analyze this and my
computer is a bit overloaded at the
moment but I promise it's really
interactive
alright so during the interview my
computer crashed so I'm doing this in
post-production just to show you how
this website operates so what you have
here is an overview over all the
channels of what rare recommendations
were collected and they're grouped into
groups for example here after partisan
left center left social justice partisan
right and so on so you can see for each
group or channel where recommendations
come from and where they go to for
example the large red one here I happen
to know that is Fox News you can see Fox
News of the daily impression it received
from itself 36 million impressions and
it gives to itself 36 billion these
numbers have to agree by nature of how
the data is collected of course but you
can also see it gets 2.7 million
impressions from CNN 2.6 million from
the next news network and so on and it
also gives quite a bit of
recommendations to CNN and so on so you
can go for example at some in
channel here's the daily wider the daily
wire is mainly run by ben shapiro so
it's a bit more to the right of fox news
and a bit more on the direction of
alternative media you can see the daily
wire gets some most of its oppression
count wise from itself from the daily
wire but it gives most of them to fox
news so actually you can see here the
itself is a long way down
like in whatever a six or seventh place
so actually if you were to watch the
daily wire the recommendation system
would most likely steer you toward
something like fox news whereas the
claim is that the YouTube algorithm
would actually steer you towards more
radical content actually in in reality
it seems like it would steer you towards
more of these mainstream content alright
so actually want to go to this tab you
can see different groupings here and the
radicalization pathways is the previous
paper we have looked at so they have all
these channels here of this
radicalization pathway and you can see
here the control group gives very very
very few impressions to the IDW the IDW
gives much more impressions to the
control group right again and the IDW
gives very few impressions to the alt
light compared to the amount of
impressions the out light gives to the
IDW and even to the control group and if
you look at the alt-right
and we're gonna zoom in on that here
it's even more so the alt-right of
course receives most of its impressions
from itself which you could expect for
any kind of group this is your classic
filter bubble situation but if we
analyze the question of is there a
pipeline you can see that next most
likely you are diverted to the IDW and
to the control group much more then you
come from the IDW or the control group
right let's look at the the alt light
so-called this is kind of the so-called
gateway to the alt-right you can see
here the alt light gives most of its
impressions next to itself to the
control group and ID Douglas OD
radicalizing if you look at its way to
the alt-right you'll see that it gets
about four times as much impressions
from the halt right as it gives to the
alt right so basically it's kind of
taking the steam out of a quarter of all
of these sessions and gives it to either
the control group or the IDW or itself
so this is exactly the opposite of what
you would expect if you were to claim
that there is a pipeline you would
expect their most recommendations to
come from more moderate content and go
towards more extreme content but it's
exactly opposite and again these are the
exact channels that this original paper
used now what this paper found the the
one that we're discussing if you go to
media type here what you'll be able to
see is the division into mainstream
media YouTube creator and so-called
missing link media which will leave out
for a moment let's focus on mainstream
versus YouTube creators you can see the
mainstream media gives most
recommendations to itself while giving
only very little recommendations to
YouTube creators and the missing link
media while the YouTube creators
actually give almost half of their
impressions look at that they they like
give almost half of their impressions to
the mainstream media which means that
there is a big big push by the algorithm
to words these mainstream media away
from YouTube creators so in general and
I invite you to look at this website in
general you can pretty much see that the
exact opposite of a radicalization
pipeline is happening if you of course
if you look at these recommendations and
how they are distributed actually most
recommendation pathways are towards more
a centrist content and of course
creating creating filter bubbles which
is a problem by itself but is not a
radicalization pipeline lastly I want to
look at white identity Rian's
because it's a one of the groups that
people are referring to when they claim
that there are these radicalization
pipelines look at that so of the white
identitarian they get most of their
impressions of course from other white
identitarian videos which would be your
filter bubble phenomenon but they give
most and this is a group right the white
identity Rhian channels give most of
their in their recommendations to the
partisan right to the central and left
mass mainstream media libertarians and
and so on and themselves are like really
really really far down so to claim that
there is this radicalization pipeline if
you look at this data to me seems not
justified from this data and if I look
at the other paper that really left out
the important analysis of the the
backwards direction
it seems that given everything it seems
that the claim is not warranted all
right
back to the interview um it's not about
like what you've done is that a good
summary of the data collection and
analysis
does it yeah it's a good summary I can
go into detail room yeah please
so YouTube doesn't make it easy so I
started this back in November in 2018
and I was using the YouTube API and to
get an F to get enough quota because
they limit the amount of requests you
can actually make to their API I created
multiple keys which is against their
policy and they also asked you to delete
all your data after 30 days that's also
part of their policy so later I think it
was October 2019 they cut off my excess
because I was doing that so I had to
move to just scraping the websites and
now my collection process actually just
load up the website and gets the
recommendations from the actual page
like a user would and that's difficult
because they block access after a couple
of hundred requests though they'll stop
you that machine from actually
requesting from the website so I need to
use a proxy service that that's fairly
expensive and what they do is they
simulate well they have actual
residential connections like through
your home connection like 80 and my
requests get tunneled through that like
a variety of locations in the States to
get a representative kind of sample
cool so the theta collection is would
you say that's that's the hardest part I
feel the labeling of channels is also
not so easy but you've you've managed to
kind of do it half automated also have
collecting things from kind of sources
that are not analyzed these channels but
if at least for for most of the things
that I've inspected I found the labeling
to be pretty sane I think this is always
something you can attack the the
original paper was also attacked on how
they labeled I I find this to be kind of
Vicarage mostly I think your labels are
pretty good as well the other paper
labels are also mostly pretty okay yeah
let's let's go to it
sorry yeah it's quite subjective I
expected the labelling to be what I get
my pushback on but it turns out it was
the anonymous collection so what you've
actually found here what are what would
you say are your your main results and I
can maybe show so you've analyzed a bit
where do things come from where do
things go to and I found this this part
here to be one of the even though it's
pretty simple one of the core things to
say about this is that mostly what you
found could be said is it's simply a
recommendation algorithm working as a
recommendation algorithm should which
means it creates you know your typical
filter bubbles if you if I watch one
makeup tutorial all of a sudden my site
is filled with makeup tutorials and
things like this but also you found that
there is quite some over-the-top push
towards what could be considered
mainstream media and there is a bit of a
draw away from the smaller youtuber like
channels is that
is that something that does that
characterize your work that's right so
it yeah that's a good way to
characterize it if that shot we're
looking at now if it was a neutral
algorithm the grain vials to be the same
as the gray ones so if you received the
same amount of recommendations as you
give that would be proportional to the
views that you get the future and all
organically the recommendations your CPU
couldn't want to that but we find that
it disproportionately recommends
mainstream media channels
that's not even though so it's not like
it doesn't look like there's
consistently doing that so you can find
exceptions to that is I believe one of
the main criticisms of your paper has
been that you only use data from 2019
onwards and I have actually looked at
your website and your website a lot of
times says that the data has been
collected from way earlier than that
so is it that you've all was only used
20:19 data in your paper or what is in
in the pipe the pipe is just from
November and December 2019 and the
reason we did that is that we only had
400 channels before that and the
collection prices have changed over time
so this is a clean set of data we could
look at and I thought the most recent
was the most relevant so what is it
doing now but I've provided I've put the
same analysis over time so I've got a
gift that I made that everyone can look
at which goes through all the months
I've been collecting and you can see
that chart for where it goes to and has
gone through a bunch of changes so in
about April 2019
that's when they really clamp down on
conspiracies and all the fringe channels
mm-hmm before that was it was much
closer to neutral ok so but it never it
never looked like a rabbit
have a favor young French channels yeah
I mean that that has been my experience
also personally on YouTube I've I've
joined YouTube very early or I've
watched you too very early when young
Earth Creationism was still active and
then these things were kind of
completely discredited by simply having
you having people exposed to other
points of view and even I find this now
even though YouTube makes it kind of
easy to find let's say niche content it
also exposes you to a bunch of different
views and and I've always find this to
be very very optimistic in the sense of
this is probably D radicalizing much
more people than radicalizing but you've
you've received like as I said a bunch
of criticism in so if you could what was
the the largest criticism irrespective
of whether it was valid or not what do
you have you found was kind of what most
people were criticizing most people
criticizing that we were collecting
anonymous recommendations it wasn't the
personal last ones yeah and it's
actually like it is a valid limitation
we had it there's a first limitation we
talked about in this paper and it's
still an open question how
personalization would affect these
aggregate results mm-hmm that we've got
but I think it's reasonable to assume it
would be quite similar
once you average it out so for any one
person it might be different but you
would expect personalization based on
someone's history to Eve it out because
it's kind of the algorithms can let the
average of all that when it's anonymous
yeah I feel a still that's an assumption
the the the the notion that if because
if you're not logged in the
recommendation is like a person with
only one video of history right so it's
the same thing but there's only one hit
point of history instead of multiple I
find why should why should the behavior
be qualitatively different if you have
multiple points of
like this is a strong claim that you
have to you'd have to really show that
there is a qualitative difference not
just a more or less accuracy and I feel
the people making this criticism or it's
really on them to show that there is a
substantial difference rather than
saying that this is a giant limitation
of the work yeah that's also very
hypocritical for a lot of the people
saying it because some of them like
designer who was mockingly saying that
her article her original article in New
York Times used how about transparency
which is anonymous as well but she
doesn't she never looked into that I
think a lot of this is completely
motivated reasoning they don't that I
care about the details
I've seen this one is one Twitter user
she she comment she said something to
the effect of if you've seen this
article please consult someone that
works in this space like it's it's
please don't don't read the article
yourself you must you must get your
information through someone I've
actually have read the article I've I
found it's pretty straightforward the
limitations are clear but also the the
results are are pretty clear and it's
it's actually mostly a boring article
right if I'm sorry like it is not a
criticism this is good like it's mostly
you find that things work as expected
there is a bit of a push towards
mainstream which can be probably
explaining that YouTube wants to be
advertiser friendly right and these
mainstream channels are already are
advertiser friendly so they probably get
bumped a bit if what would you say is
maybe the most the most valid criticism
that you've heard maybe not the biggest
but the most what do you say yeah this
is really this is really something that
is you know
I think I get what's there was criticism
that I'm over claiming not in the paper
so much but in my tweets and medium
I guess that's that's fair but I guess
when I tweet and write a medium those
are what I believe in kind of a Bayesian
way I'm not catching my claims like you
would when you're writing a paper so I
guess that's valid but I think a lot of
people ran into what I was saying
more than what I was so when I say the
algorithm has addy radicalizing
influence I'm just talking about the
recommendations whereas a lot of people
consider that to be talking about all
things considered so even if it isn't
doesn't have a bias towards a fringe
maybe sociologically youtube radicalizes
people it could be the case I don't know
but that's what I'm talking about I'm
talking about just the influence through
recommendations and that's all we can
hold Google accountable for or at least
it's what probably all could agree that
Google should be held accountable for
with its recommendation system yet do
you do you expect something to come or
have you heard something to come out of
youtube themselves like the the company
any form of official statement to this
nothing nothing at all the only I got a
vague a reporter was complaining that
YouTube sent them this so I think
they've read it but that I have no
absolutely no contact with them okay
cool are you doing any anything in
follow up or do you have plans for more
research
none of this I've just gone back to work
I've applied a bunch for a bunch of
independent grant money but I'm not
optimistic so if I don't get that I'll
keep up keep it pattering along I'll
probably reduce the amount of
recommendations because I'm spending
like about $500 a month at the moment
just keeping it running so I got
allergies my costs yeah and you do have
a patreon for people to to chip into
that right yeah so if you can link to
that that'd be good yes if I'm getting
something like like $22 a month
it doesn't really cover it yeah all
right so okay this this has been very
very pleasant I think we've we've kind
of looked at a lot of things is there
anything you would like to amend to this
that people should know about the
research or about this this field now I
just happen I encourage you to have a
play dignity date yourself this if
you're in this area the data is free to
use the cards for you to use just
consider this a contribution to
knowledge
cool well thanks a lot mark I wish you a
very pleasant evening for you I guess
and Cheers
thanks thanks having bye-bye